[Music]
everyone we here at Gamescom 2017 I'm
Lucy I'm Dave I'm PewDiePie Sharp's and
we put a pretty busy David so started up
this morning Tom and I played the evil
within yeah which was yeah it was good I
enjoyed it I think about is Shinji
Mikami being very quiet about this I say
he's not that anymore he's actually here
at Gamescom which was surprised not
directing the game though Shinji Mikami
just looking for a window at the evil
within too just to make sure things are
looking just rockin up yeah keep an eye
on everyone but it felt good like it
feels the thing that's tricky about is
it looks it feels like a mixture between
resin you will fall on a little bit of
Silent Hill and in the mind game stuff
and doing visual imagery really well
yeah but I feel thing that I walked away
thinking was it doesn't have like a a
unified kind of aesthetic or an idea
that's kind of driving it for what it
has the mental southwest like you know
what's real what's really you know mind
games and that kind of stuff but after
Resident Evil 7 I need my horror games
to be a little more tighter and little
more contain QC because it feels way
more like it's going to action horror
yeah it seems quite ironic that Resident
Evil is now the series that I think of
when I think off entick horror survival
horror in 2017 there was a time when it
absolutely wasn't and it was a time when
Mikami and maybe the evil within one was
more closer to that but this one feels a
little more like action focused and you
mention it feels a bit like Batman which
was really it doesn't feel like them but
it certainly borrows a lot of things
from Batman so there's one sequence we
were playing where you're in there's
kind of like this hub world like this
creepy village
and you're searching for your daughter
and so you're using a radio to basically
pinpoint her voice by like by location
but this was a big way you kind of
because it's set in like a ready player
one Oasis alternate I mentioned made
from someone's mind it means that you
can have these weird effects and so
there's one thing where you find your
daughter is you find sort of like the
shadow of where she was and you sort of
do a Batman recreate the crime scene and
follow footprints and stuff and it just
felt very very strange to be clear we're
not saying it is like Batman's before
you start screaming in the comments what
we're saying is like it has a similar
vibe like that dark focus moving you
along trying to use like you know the
frequency or the voice detector to kind
of guide you and in very tight corridors
going back and forth so it has like a a
vibe to it a kind of like survival
horror vibe
kind of like how it felt in in the
asylum in the first Batman game I really
liked it I mean it looks really good
Sebastian has I don't know what he's had
done but he is looking really good
Danny chisel but one thing that annoyed
me in the first game and annoyed me in
the bill that we play today is every
time there is like a really good action
set piece bit cutscene you don't get to
play that because one like really
annoying bit where you picked up a gun
and you had one bullet yeah and then it
cut you to a cutscene when this enemy
came after you and you went boom boom
boom but like actually if you can find
the number of bullets didn't see that's
not what you said there it's kind of
like my main difference the thing that's
I'm trying to kind of talk
in terms of Resident Evil seven versus
this resin he was serving the scary
being there the atmosphere of it whereas
this is like trying to scare you again
like oh here's a creepy girl walking by
on it wrestles control away from you to
do that instead of just being like you
can hear one of the you know the family
members in Resident Evil sevens mansion
just walking around and that's what
scares you and your tensions in that so
like I'm still excited about the evil
we're going to but as a survival horror
game or even a horror game I'm still
gonna left me wanting fun still excited
for you you guys play something
completely different that yeah we didn't
plan it for nearly as scary you got to
clean I don't know Star Wars is pretty
scary man Darth Vader you know have you
heard of a guy who Darth Vader have you
added breathing oh there's no breathing
oh you seem terrified every no charge
otherwise aren't shy basically all we
played was the space battle stuff space
battle and mostly we were being Empire
because yeah the next side yeah
obviously but it it's way better than
the first bathroom it's so much more
objective focused even even when you're
kind of stuck in space the objective is
very much if if I like again it was
borrowing from our field one's brush
mode yeah and it started off you were
and you had to defend the Empire's like
shield generators and cruisers and waves
of bombers were coming at you and when
they destroyed those they were like just
trying to destroy docking clamps and get
the shield
if they destroyed those those sequences
where they were flying into star
destroyers and the internals and
shooting
reactors super intensive yeah it's weird
because even when a Star Wars game is
bad it makes you feel like you're a Star
Wars which inherently makes it amazing
but this isn't bad right well absolutely
not was this felt really really good
like the controls called fine sometimes
flying ships in some games it's like
absolute nightmare this felt really
really good one thing I noticed right
quickly was it's way more generous with
like the first battlefront we were in
space agree punish you when you've just
glanced or something
yeah and that really it would always
take you out of the moment if you're
having this like amazing space battle
when you're going through Death Star
trench is you clicked a pixel of texture
Dead's absolute destroy it in the oven
please why do you do this I'm trying I
just like we still a little bit of the
card system they had so you can yet we
had the TIE fighter at AI interceptor
and a tight mama fighter obviously lots
of places going at interceptors more
powerful lasers though heats quickly
upon us obviously got lots of torpedoes
the card system allowing us like oh I
want a bit more health I want a little
bit more damage I want my Cooling's
happen fastest so whilst if you're on
the Empire basically you're supplying
the same [ __ ] they all look pretty
similar you can kind of you can tailor
aerial play star a little bit but the
best thing that they did in my opinion
was how they've done the heroes now yeah
so originally above about front one you
have to pick up these heroes bidding
orbs and then go into a Crouch crouch
positions go ahead hello I'd like to be
Darth Vader for a little bit into the
1980s stop somebody or something now you
earn you in points in battle so I was
shooting down x-wings playing object--
I was giving more points so if that cost
me a thousand points my response be
either slave 1 or pulled the side for
something it was character that I didn't
recognize I don't like a sit again for
the rebels it was like Millennium Falcon
right yeah Lando Falcon we didn't get to
play much the rebels unfortunately but
they had their own faster Pharaohs basri
nice is that if you're playing really
well as the heroes why playing a slave
one shooting that Millennium Falcon's of
my wings and a wings it was like hey
like you're a great so everyone so Kate
many more points and then when you
respawn you could be slave 1 again I
didn't get this because I played of both
heroes got some really good games
Ivysaur can put the gameplay up of that
ASAP s that should be up anytime soon
but I mean I've not paid any boots on
the ground from the mouth front to yet
well as far as the space part that goes
speaking on boots on the ground I'm very
stupid yeah I played FIFA 18 you'll be
surprised to hear it's very similar to
FIFA 17 what's different about it I mean
to get a bit right sell down everyone
Crossing is better and the shooting is
better but yeah it feels very similar it
feels very flow like really really slow
which I don't know as in compared to
previous speakers are compared to PES
both like I was always like a FIFA fan
first for like years and years and years
until about two years ago where I
thought PES had overtaken FIFA and
that's still the case now I think with
the most recent experiments they've both
slowed down this year but FIFA more so
and it was all it was slower to begin
with as well with FIFA 17 and I it just
feels really sluggish and not very it
just doesn't feel responsive like it's I
I find it quite frustrating to play
especially when defending it feels
better than did a couple months ago I
played it at preview about a couple
months ago it feels better since then so
that gives me hope
but maybe they will try and improve it
more in time for the final release but
yeah I was not hugely impressed with it
I did win though I played Bristol City
against Arsenal and I didn't - no who
are you playing again awesome
but who is playing oh I do it sets a
world class I think your point
I still see Eevee it's very realistic
yeah my paycheck I wore which wasn't the
power or dinner
I faced off against the Balrog and I had
some kind of like class no he actually
got run away yeah we're gonna have the
full gameplay up and you can see the
point where I'll leave it in the point
where I try to sneak up a step and the
game was having none of it yeah but it
was impressive
that fight is so cool it's sort of like
me respectively the boss fights in the
shadow of Mordor for example which is
sort of like you up against an ORAC and
it was like you flooded by Pilate other
or permanent this was just like me a
Balrog and an elemental spirit in the
form of like a cave troll that looked
like a tree and it was awesome it was
very quick time quick time event heavy
but it like the set pieces were
incredible you have to use like all of
your like elven powers as well as just
sort of like running around
it looked super awesome they've done
since I last played it they've clearly
done an art past and they've really
tightened up things like hugs and just
how it looks and it just tighten up the
graphical level 3 grow up with Harry but
yeah that was I love the cinematic the
way it looked and you know he had
control over there quite as the tree
spirit thing at one point I was eyeing
for hunt you this power like every punch
look like it carried away the screen was
like vibrating FX 1 X so look good run
anywhere super excited to show you the
gameplay that we got some people could
be putting that up today as well that's
all from us from Gamescom detail join us
again tomorrow date 3 we've got one go
so good stuff tomorrow like Dishonored 2
DLC now get survivor has we'll see you
then well so you met Charles Martin